i'm daniel de broken known as debbie i
am kind of engineering at work see in
new york city there's the kind of
technical debt where you are just not
qualified to do the job and you wrote
some really bad software and now
everything is falling apart within three
weeks of development your product is not
running it's not scaling it's not
performant enough it does not do the
features that your you actually wanted
it to do in the very beginning it's
worse when you keep gluing more features
on top of existing features and existing
features break so it becomes really hard
to develop the software when you realize
that you're holding a very big code base
that is very heavy to maneuver and that
is all problems that's when you know
that you have accrued too much technical
debt now there's sometimes good
technical debt technical that that you
decide to incur voluntarily a good
architect will always leave some amount
of black box in his or her software and
meaning that I don't have to implement a
particular feature to scale to a million
users right now it's good enough if it
works for a thousand and once I have
maybe 10,000 users then I have to
rethink and rewrite it but it's not
going to be a full restart I kind of
carve the box for myself inside my
application and I can just revisit a
component later that's good kind of
technical debt technical debt that I
planned for having obviously you don't
know everything up front and you don't
always know what kind of technical that
you're actually incurring that's why
experience matters so much good
engineers who have seen all kinds of
applications will be cognizant of what
kind of technical that they are accruing
they will know better where to implement
something where to leave something alone
potentially take a shortcut it's always
about trade-offs the problem is that you
never know what is going to happen in
your software application tomorrow
business changes a lot and maybe the
direction you're going in today is not
going to work tomorrow at all so
sometimes you are it's better to develop
software faster than to develop software
better as long as you are not occurring
such an amount of technical debt that it
will paralyze you as the business turns
direction